Joe Franklin?
乔·富兰克林？
I'm ready.
我准备好了。
It's Ira Glass here.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Oh, you're the emcee on the show, Ira.
哦，你是节目的主持人，艾拉。
I am the emcee on the show. Yes.
我确实是节目的主持人。是的。
Oh great. Ira? I-R-A, Ira?
太棒了。艾拉？I-R-A，艾拉？
Ira, I-R-A.
艾拉，I-R-A。
Oh, great. Now hold on one second, Ira. Don't go away. Hello? [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. Call me after 3 o'clock. I have great news for you. Ira.
哦，太好了。等一下，艾拉。别走开。喂？[听不清]。3点以后给我打电话。我有个好消息要告诉你。艾拉。
Yes.
好的。
So listen, Tony. If the phone rings, take it in the back. And then come out and tell me who it is. Just say, Joe's being with a camera crew. Just for about 10 minutes. We'll do about five minutes, 10 minutes, right, Ira?
听着，托尼。如果电话响了，去后面接。然后出来告诉我那是谁。就说，乔正和摄制组在一起。大概10分钟。我们大概做5到10分钟，对吧，艾拉？
That's right.
没错。
Well, one great thing about starting a new show is utter anonymity. Nobody really knows what to expect from you. This interviewee did not know us from Adam.
嗯，开启一档新节目的一大好处就是完全的默默无闻。没人知道会对你有什么期待。这位受访者以前根本不认识我们。
OK, we're what? About a minute. We're one minute five into the new show. Right now, it is stretching in front of us, a perfect future yet to be fulfilled. An uncharted little world. A little baby coming into the world, no little scars on it or anything.
好了，我们现在进展如何？大约一分钟。新节目开始一分零五秒了。此时此刻，一个尚未实现的完美未来展现在我们面前。一个尚未被探索的小世界。一个刚刚来到世上的小婴儿，身上没有任何伤疤之类的东西。
Nobody hearing my words right now is thinking, "Oh, man, remember that show, back when it used to be good? That show, I never missed that show back in the old days, back in the first couple years before it got so-called popular. Back when it was still good."
现在听到我说话的人，没有人会想：“噢，伙计，还记得那个节目吗，在它还不错的时候？那个节目，我过去从没错过那个节目，在早期还没变得所谓出名的时候。在它还不错的时候。”
No, actually, I think that force, that human desire to say that is so strong, to say that "I was there back when that show was good," that force is so strong, it is so basic to who we are as people that I know-- OK, what are we? We are two minutes into the program-- I know that somewhere out there, one or two of you are saying, "Oh, sure. I used to listen to that show back in the first 30 seconds, back when it used to be really good. Remember back when they used to do all that crazy stuff? When they had that guy on the phone? Remember back then?"
不，其实我觉得那种力量，那种想要说“我当时就在那儿，在那节目不错的时候”的人类欲望非常强烈，这种力量非常基础，是我们作为人的一部分，所以我知道——好了，我们进展到哪了？节目开始两分钟了——我知道在外面某个地方，你们中有一两个人正在说：“哦，当然。我过去常听那个节目，在头30秒的时候，在它还真的很不错的时候。还记得他们过去做那些疯狂事情的时候吗？当他们让那个人在电话里的时候？还记得那时候吗？”
Well, from WBEZ, in the glorious city of Chicago, Illinois. The name of this show is Your Radio Playhouse. I'm your emcee. I'm your emcee, Ira Glass.
那么，来自伊利诺伊州光荣的芝加哥市，WBEZ电台。这档节目的名字叫《你的广播剧场》。我是你们的主持人。我是你们的主持人，艾拉·格拉斯。
OK, the idea of this show, this new little show, is stories, some by journalists and documentary producers, like myself, some just regular people telling their own little stories, some by artists, and writers, and performers of all different kinds. And the idea is we're going to bring you stuff you're not going to find anywhere else. And there is also going to be music.
好的，这档节目，这个新节目，它的创意是讲述故事，有些是由像我这样的记者和纪录片制作人讲述的，有些是普通人讲述他们自己的小故事，还有些由各类艺术家、作家和表演者讲述。我们的想法是带给你们在其他任何地方都找不到的内容。当然也会有音乐。
And tonight's show, we thought that we would have a theme. Tonight's show is going to be New Beginnings. And to kick things off, I called the man who's had, as best as anybody can tell, the longest running program in the history of television. His name is Joe Franklin, and his program ran for 43 years on local television in New York. And he claims that he invented the talk show format. And I called him to get some advice on how to create a long-running, healthy program.
关于今晚的节目，我们想设定一个主题。今晚节目的主题是“新的开始”。为了拉开序幕，我打电话给那位据大家所知，拥有电视史上播放时间最长节目的人。他的名字叫乔·富兰克林，他的节目在纽约当地电视台播出了43年。他声称他发明了谈话节目的形式。我打电话给他，是为了请教如何创造一档长寿且健康的节目。
I've been called in many times to give a sort of a Dean, the elder statesman, even though I'm still a young kid. But I've been called in to give this kind of advice to new kids on the block. Conan O'Brien had me on his first show. And people like that. There's no guidance. It's a matter of paying attention.
我曾多次被叫去担任某种“院长”或长辈的角色，尽管我还很年轻。但我经常被请去给这些新人建议。柯南·奥布莱恩在他的第一个节目中请过我。还有像他那样的人。没有什么指导。关键在于用心。
Your voice, I've heard so much about the sparkle, about the energy in your voice. The voice, on radio especially, is everything. And when the guest is sitting with you, you've got to look into his eyes. Many times, you get an author on there who's begrudgingly sitting there. He'd rather be home in his ivory tower.
你的声音，我听说过很多关于你声音中那种闪光点和活力的评价。声音，尤其是在广播中，就是一切。当嘉宾坐在你对面时，你必须直视他的眼睛。很多时候，你请到一位作者，他却心不甘情不愿地坐在那儿。他宁愿待在他象牙塔里的家中。
And above all, get the plug fast. Otherwise, he's worried you're not going to make the plug for the book. And I created a line, Ira, that's been picked up by George Burns. I always said, the main ingredient for longevity in the talk show field, where the mortality rate is so staggering, the main ingredient is sincerity. And once you learn to fake that, then you got it made. I made that up. And I just played it by ear. I was a natural born talker, I guess.
最重要的是，赶紧插播广告。否则，他会担心你没有为他的书做宣传。我创造了一句台词，艾拉，后来被乔治·伯恩斯采纳了。我总是说，在死亡率如此惊人的谈话节目领域，长寿的主要秘诀就是真诚。一旦你学会了伪装成那样，你就成功了。那是我编出来的。我只是见机行事。我想我是一个天生的谈话者。
So let me just summarize what I'm getting from you. You're saying you should just pay attention, look people in the eye, be sincere when I'm on the air, get in the plug early.
让我总结一下我从你那得到的信息。你是说应该用心，直视别人的眼睛，在播出时保持真诚，早点植入广告。
That's the key. And don't look in their nose or their belly button. Look right in the eye. Eye contact is everything. And as I say, it's a lot of fun.
这就是关键。不要盯着他们的鼻子或肚脐。要直视眼睛。眼神交流就是一切。而且正如我所说，这非常有趣。
And I never called anybody in my life to come on to my show. And I'm sure that they'll be coming to you too. I heard about you, and I called you and wanted to wish you good look, Ira. Imagine the thrill of John F. Kennedy walking into my studio. Richard Nixon. Ronald Reagan, five times. And Bing Crosby.
我这辈子从来没给任何人打过电话请他们上我的节目。我相信他们也会主动找你。我听说过你，所以我打电话给你，祝你好运，艾拉。想象一下约翰·F·肯尼迪走进我的演播室的那种激动。理查德·尼克松。罗纳德·里根，五次。还有宾·克罗斯比。
And I've got a major book out right now, by the way, Ira, called Up Late with Joe Franklin from Simon & Schuster. And if you find a copy in the store--
顺便说一下，艾拉，我现在有一本大作出版，书名是《与乔·富兰克林彻夜长谈》，西蒙与舒斯特出版社出版。如果你在书店看到了副本——
You see now, I guess I've sort of messed that one up, because I didn't let you get in your plug early.
你瞧，我想我把那次搞砸了，因为我没让你早点植入你的广告。
See, that is my fault. I got it in toward the bitter end. It's like Duke Ellington. He always used to have his dessert at the beginning of the meal. Duke Ellington said, because he would never have no room for it at the end. So he had his dessert at the beginning. Who is it? Well, no, good news, 6 o'clock.
看，那是我的错。我是在最后才提出来的。这就像艾灵顿公爵。他总是把甜点放在餐前吃。艾灵顿公爵说，因为他最后就没地方吃了。所以他把甜点放在开头吃。是谁？好吧，不，好消息，6点。
Well, Joe Franklin, thank you very much for being with us on our premier show.
好的，乔·富兰克林，非常感谢你能参加我们的首播节目。
Ira, I'm going to be a listener and a fan. And let's always be in touch.
艾拉，我会成为你的听众和粉丝。让我们保持联系。
[MUSIC - "DESTINATION MOON" BY DINAH WASHINGTON]
[音乐 - 黛娜·华盛顿的《奔向月球》]
All right, Your Radio Playhouse. All right. I'm making eye contact with you right-- wait, how does Joe put it? Wait a second.
好的，《你的广播剧场》。好的。我正在和你进行眼神交流——等等，乔是怎么说的？等一下。
Look right in the eye. Eye contact is everything.
直视眼睛。眼神交流就是一切。
I am making eye contact with you right now. That is just how much I have already learned. OK, so the thing about new beginnings is that there are the ones that we actually undertake and then there are the ones that we just wish for. And the ones that we wish for pretty much outnumber the ones that we really undertake.
我此刻正在和你进行眼神交流。这就是我已经学到的东西。好的，关于新的开始，有些是我们真正去做的，有些是我们只是希望的。而我们希望的那些，数量远多于我们真正去做的。
Well, Kevin Kelly spent most of his twenties wandering around Asia. He was basically wandering around as a freelance photographer. And he found himself photographing a lot of religious ceremonies and drawn to religious ceremonies of all sorts. And he says that he was really confused about what he believed. And he was the kind of person who had always dreamt about a new beginning, where he wouldn't struggle with these questions.
凯文·凯利二十多岁时大部分时间都在亚洲游荡。他基本上是以自由摄影师的身份四处流浪。他发现自己拍摄了很多宗教仪式，并被各种宗教仪式所吸引。他说他真的对自己的信仰感到困惑。他是一个一直梦想着有一个新的开始，在那里他不必再纠结于这些问题的人。
I would get twisted and caught up. And these things were in the background, consuming me. And actually, I found that I could think about little else for many, many months, that behind all that I was doing, there was always this unresolved question of was God real. And if he was real, then how could we ignore him? And if we were trying to not ignore him, what would we do? And if he was real, then what about these other things that people said about God?
我会变得纠结和困惑。这些事情在背景中消耗着我。实际上，我发现有许多个月我几乎无法思考别的事情，我所做的一切背后，始终存在着这个悬而未决的问题：上帝是真的吗？如果他是真的，那我们怎么能忽视他呢？如果我们试图不忽视他，我们该怎么做？如果他是真的，那么人们关于上帝说的那些其他事情又该怎么解释呢？
We will not attempt to answer these questions, by the way, in this hour. I just want to just give you a sense of scope here, just modest scope. But what we want to talk about is what happened to Kevin Kelly. What happened is that at the age of 27, all of this changed when he came into Jerusalem on the eve of Easter and Passover. It was the same weekend. And flocks of people are coming into the city.
顺便说一下，在这一个小时里，我们不会试图回答这些问题。我只是想让你感受一下范围，仅仅是适度的范围。但我们想谈的是凯文·凯利身上发生了什么。事情是这样的，27岁那年，当他在复活节和逾越节前夕来到耶路撒冷时，一切都改变了。那是同一个周末。成群结队的人涌入这座城市。
So I entered Jerusalem on Easter with a simple expectation that I was going to photograph another religious ceremony, another religious festival. And then, for various reasons, I got locked out of my hostel room. They had a curfew. And I didn't make it back in time. And I was in quite a fix because I was a stranger in this very strange town. When it happened, I didn't have enough money to stay elsewhere, nor did I even have knowledge of where to go.
所以，我在复活节进入耶路撒冷时，仅仅怀着一个简单的期望，那就是去拍摄另一场宗教仪式，另一场宗教节日。然后，由于各种原因，我被锁在了宿舍房间外面。他们有宵禁。我没能及时赶回来。我陷入了困境，因为我是这个极其陌生的城镇里的一个陌生人。事情发生时，我没有足够的钱去别的地方住，也不知道该去哪里。
So I wandered the Old Town of Jerusalem at night, which had been shuttered up and was like a time machine. It was as if I had been transported back to the 15th century, because all the souvenir vendors were gone, and what was left were the labyrinthian paths of cobbled passageways. And I wandered around for a number of hours, and it was getting colder. Eventually, I found myself at the one place that was still open, which was some of the churches. And particularly, after wandering around until about 2:00 or 3:00 in the morning, I finally settled into the Church of the Holy Scepter, which is called and viewed as the church built over the mound where Jesus Christ was crucified.
所以，我在夜晚游荡在耶路撒冷的老城区，那里已经关门闭户，就像时光机器一样。仿佛我被带回了15世纪，因为所有的纪念品小贩都消失了，剩下的是鹅卵石铺就的迷宫般的通道。我游荡了几个小时，天气越来越冷。最终，我发现自己来到了唯一还开放的地方，那就是一些教堂。特别是，在游荡到凌晨2点或3点左右后，我终于在圣墓教堂安顿下来，那里被称为并被视为耶稣基督被钉死在十字架上的土墩上建造的教堂。
And I was getting very tired. And there weren't many people around. And so eventually, I laid myself out on about the only flat area that was left, which was this marble slab underneath some pendants that had incense on them. And this was presumably the slab that commemorated the exact positioning of the crosses. So I slept there. I slept on the crucifixion spot on that night because it was the only place-- they had no place in the inn.
我变得非常疲惫。周围没几个人。于是最终，我躺在了唯一剩下的平坦区域上，那是挂着香炉的吊灯下面的一块大理石板。这大概就是纪念十字架确切位置的石板。所以我睡在那里。那天晚上我睡在受难点，因为我没有别的地方可去——旅店已经没有空位了。
I slept there until early morning, when the activity started to increase, and people started coming in. And I went out and followed the crowd where it was going when they were going out to the tombs area in Jerusalem. And I went out. And there were some folding chairs set up in front of this tomb area. And as the sun was coming up on that Easter morning, I was staring at empty tombs. And for a reason that I can not comprehend, as I sat on that chair contemplating this view of the early sun morning coming into the empty tombs, all that I had been wrestling with for the past many, many years in thinking about religion sort of became resolved in my mind. And at that very moment, I believed that Jesus Christ had, indeed, risen from those tombs.
我在那里睡到清晨，活动开始增加，人们开始进来。我走出去，跟随人群去了耶路撒冷的墓地区域。我出去了。在墓区前摆放了一些折叠椅。当复活节早晨太阳升起时，我盯着空荡荡的坟墓。出于一种我无法理解的原因，当我坐在椅子上凝视着晨曦射入空坟墓的情景时，过去许多年来我在思考宗教问题上所纠结的一切，都在我脑海中迎刃而解了。就在那一刻，我相信耶稣基督确实从那些坟墓中复活了。
In an instant, the tension of trying to figure things out was resolved, because now, suddenly, everything was figured out. It was as if you had been working on a problem for a long time and suddenly the answer was there. And it was very clear that was the answer. And although there were many things that were still not clear to you, you were very certain that you were on the right path.
瞬间，试图理清一切的压力消失了，因为现在，突然间，一切都理清了。就好像你一直在钻研一道难题，突然答案就出现了。而且很清楚那就是答案。虽然还有很多事情你仍然不清楚，但你非常确定自己走在正确的道路上。
Having that realization that I believe that Jesus Christ had actually risen from those tombs did not settle 1,001 other things about what one was supposed to do with that, what I was supposed to do with that. Did that mean I was supposed to be a monk? Did that mean I was supposed to be an evangelist?
有了这种认识，即我相信耶稣基督确实从坟墓中复活了，并没有解决关于一个人应该如何做，关于我应该怎么做的那1001个其他问题。那意味着我应该成为一名僧侣吗？那意味着我应该成为一名传教士吗？
Did that mean that I had to immediately renounce all that I had, and get into sackcloths and ashes, and march out into the desert? All that was left unopened. And that is, in fact, what occupied my mind as I went back to my hostel to lay down and think about. Because I had no clue what it really meant to me ultimately, and that's what I was pondering when I was laying there napping. And I wouldn't say it was a voice, but there was an idea that came into my mind that just would not go away, and that was that I should live as if I would die in six months, that I should really, truly live. And that I could not tell for certain whether I would really die, but that either way, I should live as if I was going to die. And so that was the assignment.
那意味着我必须立即放弃我拥有的一切，穿上麻衣和灰烬，走进沙漠吗？所有这些问题都尚未打开。事实上，这就是我回到宿舍躺下思考时占据我脑海的东西。因为我根本不知道这对我是什么最终意义，这就是我在那里小睡时思考的问题。我不会说这是一个声音，但我的脑海里产生了一个念头，它就是挥之不去，那就是我应该像只剩下六个月寿命一样生活，我应该真正地、切实地生活。我不能确定我是不是真的会死，但无论如何，我都应该像我要死了一样生活。这就是任务。
I'm a pretty rational person. I'm pretty logical. And after thinking the thought that I should live as if I was going to die in six months, the first thought that comes to my head was, "Well, that's pretty silly. I have no evidence whatsoever. I could live like I'm going to die in six months and not die at all. It would just be an interesting exercise."
我是个相当理性的人。我很讲逻辑。在想到“我应该像只剩下六个月寿命一样生活”这个念头后，我脑中闪过的第一个想法是：“嗯，这太愚蠢了。我没有任何证据。我可能活得像只剩六个月一样，结果根本没死。那不过是一个有趣的练习。”
But at the same time, it was equally probable that I might die in six months. It happened all the time. There was no guarantee that I wouldn't die. And so fairly quickly, I decided that I could not settle that issue of whether I would really die or not, or just think that I was going to die in six months, and that, in either case, the important thing was to live as if I really believed that I was going to die in six months, which is what I set out to do.
但与此同时，我确实有可能会在六个月内死去。这种事随时都在发生。没有任何保证我不会死。所以很快，我决定我无法解决“我是否真的会死”或者“只是以为自己会死”的问题，而且无论哪种情况，重要的是像我真的相信自己还有六个月寿命一样去生活，这就是我着手去做的事情。
The next couple days, I had the joyous experience of saying to myself, "OK, what do I do for six months if I have only six months to live?" And the answers to that surprised me as much as the assignment, because after thinking that through and contemplating it, the conclusion that I came to was that what I wanted to do for six months was to go home and be ordinary, to go back to my parents, to help them take out the trash, and trim the hedges, and move furniture around, and to be with them. And I was really shocked by that, because I thought that with six months to live, I would climb Mount Everest, or I would go scuba diving to the depths of the ocean, or get in a speedboat and see how fast I could go. But instead, I wanted to go back home and be with my family for that time.
接下来的几天，我经历了一种快乐，对自己说：“好吧，如果我只剩下六个月的生命，我该做什么？”这些答案让我和这个任务本身一样感到惊讶，因为在思考和斟酌之后，我得出的结论是，我想在六个月内做的事情就是回家，做一个平凡的人，回到父母身边，帮他们倒垃圾、修剪树篱、搬动家具，和他们在一起。我对此感到非常震惊，因为我以为，既然只剩下六个月的生命，我会去攀登珠穆朗玛峰，或者去深海潜水，或者坐上快艇看看我能开多快。但相反，我想回家，在那段时间里和我的家人在一起。
I, of course, did not tell anybody my crazy idea. This is, in fact, the first time I'm really talking about it publicly. Because it's a very scary and alarming idea. And I never told anybody why I was coming home.
当然，我没有告诉任何人我这个疯狂的想法。事实上，这是我第一次真正公开谈论它。因为它是一个非常可怕和惊人的想法。我从没告诉过任何人我为什么回家。
I got back to where my parents live in New Jersey, and things were unbelievably ordinary. And yet, I found myself relishing the ordinariness and finding it in some ways as exotic as anything that I had traveled to see. I helped around the house. I dug up shrubs. I worked on a deck. I moved furniture, washed dishes.
我回到了父母在纽泽西居住的地方，一切都显得不可思议地平凡。然而，我发现自己享受着这种平凡，并在某些方面觉得它和我曾旅行去过的地方一样充满异国情调。我帮着做家务，挖灌木，修露台，搬家具，洗碗。
And I was intending to spend my last remaining six months at home getting to know my parents better and myself, hopefully. But about three months into that, my travel urges, I guess, got the better of me. And what I was most concerned about was I wanted to see my brothers and sisters. I had four brothers and sisters. And they were scattered all across the country. And so I felt very strongly that I wanted to see them before I died. And I got the idea that the way to see them was to ride my bicycle across the country and visit them on bicycle.
我打算在家里度过剩下的六个月，更好地了解父母，也希望了解自己。但大约过了三个月，我的旅行欲望，我想，战胜了我。我最关心的是我想见见我的兄弟姐妹。我有四个兄弟姐妹。他们散布在全国各地。所以我强烈地感到在死前我想见见他们。我产生了一个想法，见他们的方法就是骑自行车横穿全国，骑行去拜访他们。
But before I did that, I made up a will to dispose of the little things that I had. And I had some money left over. And one of the things I did with that money was I went to the bank and got some cashier's checks for $500 and $1,000. And I mailed the money to various people anonymously as gifts. And I think giving away those thousands of dollars was the first true act of charity I had ever done. Because there was absolutely no way for any kind of gratitude or elevated feelings to come back to me, because the people had no idea who had sent them that money.
但在做那件事之前，我立了一份遗嘱，处理了我剩下的一点点东西。我手里还剩下一些钱。我用那些钱做的一件事就是去了银行，开了几张500美元和1000美元的本票。我匿名把钱邮寄给了不同的人作为礼物。我想，捐出那几千美元是我做过的第一个真正的慈善行为。因为没有任何方式让感激之情或崇高的感觉传回给我，因为那些人根本不知道是谁寄给他们的钱。
It was really remarkable to see the consequences of getting an anonymous gift like that. Because when you get a check for $1,000 in the mail, you immediately become suspicious of all your friends of having given that to you. And so there's this suspicion of charity, suspicion of goodness that starts to infect the people that are around you. And you look at someone, you think, "Hm, I wonder if he gave me that $1,000?"
看到收到匿名礼物的后果真是太显眼了。因为当你在信中收到一张1000美元的支票时，你立刻就会怀疑你所有的朋友是不是给了你这笔钱。于是，这种对慈善的怀疑、对善良的怀疑开始感染你周围的人。你看着某个人，心想：“嗯，不知道是不是他给了我那1000美元？”
Does that make sense? You look at them, and you think, "I wonder if he gave me that $1,000?" And then you act really nice to him. And then the next person you see, the next of your friends, you think, "Could this be the person?" And then you act really nice to them.
这有道理吗？你看着他们，心想：“不知道是不是他给了我那1000美元？”然后你对他们表现得非常好。然后你看到的下一个人，你的下一个朋友，你会想：“这会不会是那个人？”然后你对他们表现得非常好。
I almost want to begin a little speech here about let us all now take up this practice. All of us. Everyone within the sound of my voice. If we all could just do this right now, then I would believe that our little radio show, just 19 minutes into the program, had contributed in some way.
我几乎想在这里发表一个小演讲，呼吁我们所有人都开始这种实践。我们所有人。每一个听到我声音的人。如果我们现在都能做到这一点，那么我会认为我们的这个小广播节目，在开播仅19分钟时，就已经做出了某种贡献。
I had enough money left over to basically pay for food and whatnot on my bicycle journey across America. And the path that I had to visit all my brothers and sisters was not a direct route, going from San Francisco to New York. I actually had to go up to Idaho, and back down to Texas, and then back up through Indiana. So it was a 5,000 mile trip. The day which, coincidentally, was exactly six months from when I had this assignment, was October 31. It was Halloween. And so the plan would be that I would ride back home, so that I would come back to die on the day after Halloween.
我剩下的钱基本上够支付我横穿美国自行车之旅的食物和杂费。我为了拜访所有兄弟姐妹所走的路线并不是一条直线，从旧金山到纽约。我实际上不得不绕道去爱达荷，再回到德克萨斯，然后穿过印第安纳回到家。所以这是一次5000英里的旅行。那天，巧合的是，距离我接到这个任务整整六个月，正好是10月31日。那是万圣节。所以计划是，我骑车回家，在万圣节的第二天回来死去。
I think there are a lot of people who have trouble staying in the present. There are some people who like to slip into the past as a means to perhaps fantasize or escape. And they find that the past is the place that they retreat to. And I often retreat to the future. I was not a person who planned or had a career staged out, or who had a particular woman he wanted to marry some day, or some vision of a house. The future that I found so hard to give up was a much more insidious type.
我认为有很多人在停留在当下这件事上有困难。有些人喜欢滑向过去，作为一种幻想或逃避的方式。他们发现过去是他们退守的地方。而我经常退守到未来。我不是一个有计划、有职业规划、或者有某个特定想娶的女人、或者有某种对房子憧憬的人。我发现那种难以放弃的未来是一种更阴险的类型。
It was that of I'd like to buy this record because, in the future, I want to hear this song again and again. Or I will read this book, and there are some cool ideas in it because someday I may write an article about this. And it's good to know that. There was a sense in which my entire life was shifted to the future. And the thought of doing something now for the enjoyment, or the pleasures, or the principle of the function of just right now, without any sense at all that it would ever be used again or that it could ever be brought forward, was extremely difficult and disconcerting. And I fought it day by day and tooth by tooth.
那就是：“我想买这张唱片，因为在未来，我想一次又一次地听到这首歌。”或者“我会读这本书，里面有一些很酷的想法，因为有一天我可能会写一篇关于这个的文章。”知道这一点很好。在某种意义上，我的整个生活都转移到了未来。而那种仅仅为了享受、快乐，或者为了当下而做某事的想法，完全没有任何它会被再次利用或被带入未来的感觉，是非常困难和令人不安的。我一天天地抗争，咬牙坚持。
One of the ways I dealt with this was that I was actually able, by the last weeks, to not think about my life beyond Halloween. There was a way which I had just-- each time a thought came up about something that was beyond this horizon, I just said, "Nope, can't think about it. It doesn't work. We have to dwell in the present."
我处理这个问题的方法之一是，在最后几周，我实际上能够不考虑万圣节之后的生活。每当出现关于地平线之外的事情的想法时，我就只是说：“不行，不能想它。没用的。我们必须活在当下。”
And at the same time I was doing that, and I was able to do that, I also decided that it was an entirely unnatural and inhumane way to live. And that having a future is part of what being human is about. And that when you take away the future for humans, you take away a lot of their humanness. And that it's not actually a very good thing to live entirely in the present. That one needs to have a past, and one needs to have a future to be fully human.
与此同时，当我这样做，并且能够做到的时候，我也认为这是一种完全不自然和不人道的生活方式。拥有未来是作为人类的一部分。当你夺走人类的未来时，你就夺走了他们许多的人性。完全活在当下其实并不是一件好事。一个人需要拥有过去，也需要拥有未来才能成为完整的人。
It was a journey that began at the tomb of Jesus. And as I set off to my own presumed death, I did, indeed, think about Jesus Christ who, according to the Gospels, surrendered his own life in a very knowing way. So we have the history in the Gospels of Jesus's torment in his soul, as he approached what he knew of his anointed time to die. So it was, again, that very harsh information of knowing when you're going to die.
这是一段始于耶稣坟墓的旅程。当我踏上我那假定的死亡之旅时，我确实想到了耶稣基督，根据福音书，他以一种非常清醒的方式放弃了自己的生命。所以我们在福音书中有关于耶稣灵魂痛苦的历史，当他接近他所知道的被神圣预定的死亡时刻时。所以，这又是那种知道自己何时会死的严酷信息。
And Jesus's soul was in great turmoil and pain because of knowing that. And I think I did experience some of that, not because I had the same weight. It was just my own life. But Jesus prayed that this burden be lifted, and there were days when I did pray that, that if I didn't have to die, I really would rather not.
耶稣的灵魂因为知道这一点而陷入了极大的动荡和痛苦。我想我确实经历了一些那种感觉，不是因为我有同样的重担。那只是我自己的生命。但耶稣祈祷这重担能被解除，确实有几天我也那样祈祷过，如果我不必死，我真的宁愿不死。
By late fall, I was pedaling through the Appalachians, and it was getting colder and colder. And my hands were freezing on the bicycles, and there was ice on my tents in the morning when I got up. And as each day went on, I was coming closer and closer to terrain that I was familiar with and that felt like home. And I was riding into New Jersey, and I was elated. I was elated that I had accomplished this long journey. And I was elated that I was home to see my parents.
深秋时节，我正蹬着车穿过阿巴拉契亚山脉，天气越来越冷。我在自行车上的手冻僵了，每天早上起来帐篷上都有冰。随着每一天的过去，我越来越接近我熟悉的、感觉像家一样的地方。我骑行进入纽泽西，我欣喜若狂。我为自己完成了这趟漫长的旅程而欣喜若狂。我为能回到家见到父母而欣喜若狂。
And I came in to their house on Halloween day. And I was so filled with ideas, and things, and emotions, that I didn't really say very much. And again, I couldn't say very much. I think we had a wonderful dinner. They were, of course, glad to see me because they hadn't seen me in a long time. They knew I was coming back, and we had a wonderful dinner.
我在万圣节那天到了他们家。我充满了想法、事物和情感，以至于我没说太多话。而且，我确实说不了太多。我想我们吃了一顿美妙的晚餐。他们当然很高兴见到我，因为他们很久没见到我了。他们知道我会回来，我们吃了一顿美妙的晚餐。
We had baskets of candy, which I gave out to the kids. And we had a discussion that night which was about nothing in particular. It was not about the future. It was just about, I think, talking about our family and my brothers and sisters. And I was telling them all that I  had learned about them. And so it was a very together and, again, not a very dramatic evening, but just a pleasant one, one that you might have a memory about as you were dying, which was not a special evening, but just an ordinary evening.
我们有几篮糖果，我分给了孩子们。那天晚上我们进行了一次谈话，并没有什么特别的主题。它不是关于未来的。我想只是在谈论我们的家庭和我的兄弟姐妹。我告诉了他们我所了解到的一切。所以这是一个非常团结的夜晚，当然，不是一个非常戏剧性的夜晚，只是一个愉快的夜晚，一个你可能会在临终时回忆起的夜晚，那不是一个特别的夜晚，只是一个平凡的夜晚。
And I went to bed that night, which was a very difficult thing to do because I was fully prepared at that point never to wake up again. I had been praying. I had gotten everything arranged. I had fully gone through in my own mind, in my own soul, all the things that I might have regretted. And I had righted as many of those as I thought I could through letters. And I was prepared, as much as anybody could be prepared to die.
那天晚上我上床睡觉了，这是一件非常困难的事情，因为我当时已经做好了完全的准备，再也不会醒来了。我一直在祈祷。我已经安排好了一切。我在自己的脑海里，在自己的灵魂里，彻底理清了所有我可能感到遗憾的事情。通过书信，我纠正了尽可能多我认为能纠正的事情。我做好了准备，像任何人能为死亡所做的那样准备好了。
And so I went to bed while the kids were still ringing doorbells. And I went to sleep, because I was very tired after that long trip. And I didn't know what was going to happen the next day. I thought I had done all that I could. And the next morning, I woke up. And the next morning, I woke up, and it was as if-- The next morning I woke up, and it was as if I had the entire-- my entire life again.
所以，当孩子们还在敲门讨要糖果时，我就上床睡觉了。我睡着了，因为长途跋涉后我非常累。我不知道第二天会发生什么。我想我已经尽我所能了。第二天早上，我醒了。第二天早上，我醒了，就好像——第二天早上我醒了，就好像我拥有了整个——拥有了我的整个生命。
The next morning, I woke up, and I had my entire life again. I had my future again. There was nothing special about the day. It was another ordinary day. I was reborn into ordinariness. But what more could one ask for?
第二天早上，我醒了，我又拥有了整个生命。我又拥有了未来。这一天并没有什么特别的。这是另一个平凡的日子。我重生在平凡之中。但一个人还能要求什么呢？
Well, Kevin Kelly is 43 now. That happened when he was 27. In his latest rebirth, he is the executive editor of Wired magazine, a glossy magazine about the future and the present. He told us that he wasn't even sure he has ever even told his parents this story, even this many years later. Anyway, he spoke with me and Paul Tough from the studios of KQED in San Francisco. This is Your Radio Playhouse on WBEZ Chicago.
嗯，凯文·凯利现在43岁了。那件事发生在他27岁时。在他的最新重生中，他是《连线》杂志的执行主编，《连线》是一本关于未来和当下的时尚杂志。他告诉我们，甚至这么多年以后，他甚至不确定自己是否向父母讲过这个故事。总之，他是在旧金山的KQED工作室与我和保罗·塔夫交谈的。这是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《你的广播剧场》。
Good morning. Glass, Jacobson & Associates.
早上好。格拉斯、雅各布森联合公司。
Hey, is Barry there?
嘿，巴里在吗？
Pardon me?
你说什么？
Is Barry there?
巴里在吗？
Yes, he is. He's on another call. Do you wish to hold, or I could take a message, or you can leave one on his voicemail?
是的，他在。他在接另一个电话。你想留下来等，还是我可以帮你传个话，或者你可以在他的语音信箱留言？
It's his son.
我是他儿子。
Uh-huh.
哦，好的。
Isn't this starting to sound like-- this little dialogue-- isn't it starting to sound like an episode of Dr. Katz? You know that TV show? "This is his son." "Uh-huh. Yeah." Anyway, so I thought I would call my parents in Baltimore and ask for advice on this, our first evening of our brand new radio show, Your Radio Playhouse.
这听起来不像……这段小对话……听起来不像《凯茨医生》那一集吗？你知道那个电视节目吗？“这是他儿子。”“哦，好的。嗯。”总之，我想给我在巴尔的摩的父母打电话，请教一下关于今晚，我们全新广播节目《你的广播剧场》的第一期节目，有什么建议。
Can I leave a message with you? Or is it better to use his voicemail?
我可以给你留个口信吗？还是用他的语音信箱比较好？
It doesn't matter. I'll put it right on his voicemail.
没关系。我会直接转到他的语音信箱。
OK, let's do.
好的，就这样吧。
OK, hold on, please.
好的，请稍等。
[MUSIC - "NICE 'N' EASY" BY FRANK SINATRA]
[音乐 - 法兰克·辛纳屈的《轻松随意》]
This is the story of my childhood right there. Dad is a little too busy to talk. But there's the recording of Frank Sinatra when needed.
这就是我童年故事的写照。爸爸总是太忙没空聊天，但需要的时候，总能听到弗兰克·辛纳屈的录音。
[TELEPHONE RINGING]
[电话铃响]
Hello?
喂？
Hey, Mom.
嘿，妈。
Oh, hi, Ira.
哦，你好，艾拉。
How you doing?
你怎么样？
Fine. Can you hold on a second?
挺好的。你能等一下吗？
Sure.
好的。
This is what it's like with my parents. They're so busy. Call them. Put on hold. [SINGING] Baby, what's your hurry?
这就是我和我父母相处的样子。他们太忙了。打给他们，然后被要求等待。[歌唱] 宝贝，你急什么？
When I call my little sister, she works at Disney, and so there's Disney music playing on the hold system. But there's a lot of Disney music. And there's a lot of it that peo--
我打给我妹妹的时候，她在迪士尼工作，所以等待系统里会播放迪士尼音乐。但是迪士尼音乐有很多，其中有很多人们——
Hi.
嗨。
Hi, Mom.
嗨，妈。
Yeah.
嗯。
It's me.
是我。
Yeah.
嗯。
Listen, can I record a quick conversation with you about something?
听着，我能录一段关于某件事的简短对话吗？
What about?
关于什么？
Well, you know the new show goes on the air this week. And as part of the show, we were thinking about having me call around to different people and get advice from them. And I wanted to know if you would have any advice.
嗯，你知道新节目这周就要开播了。作为节目的一部分，我们在考虑让我给不同的人打电话寻求建议。我想知道你有没有什么建议。
Hm. Do I have any advice? Well, can I ask another question?
嗯。我有什么建议吗？嗯，我可以问另一个问题吗？
Sure.
当然。
Who is your target audience?
你的目标受众是谁？
You are such a pro.
你真是个行家。
I'm saying that you're in danger of appealing to a narrow range of listeners if it becomes a little too-- I don't know what word to use.
我是说，如果节目变得太——我不知道该用什么词，你会有流失一部分听众的风险。
Artsy.
艺术化。
Artsy, yeah.
对，艺术化。
Are you and Dad still worried about me making a living in public radio? I know just for years, you were urging me to just get out and get, basically, any job in TV that I possibly could. But now that I've got my own show, are you guys still worried? Or do you feel like things are going OK? Do you want me to get into television still?
你和爸爸还在担心我靠公共广播维生吗？我知道多年来你们一直催我离开，去找一份尽可能好的电视工作。但现在我已经有了自己的节目，你们还担心吗？还是觉得一切都还行？你们还是希望我进入电视行业吗？
Now that Hugh Grant is such a big star, and everybody who sees you or sees your picture thinks how much you look like Hugh Grant, that fires up that TV thing again in me.
现在休·格兰特那么红，每个见到你或看到你照片的人都觉得你长得有多像休·格兰特，这又让我燃起了那种让你去搞电视的想法。
All right. I'm stopping the tape. This is me live. That was the tape. Only my mother could possibly believe this. Only a mother could pretty much believe this. Other adults see me, and the thought that goes through their head is not Hugh Grant. The thought that goes through their head is tall Jew.
好了。我停掉录音了。这是现场的我。刚才那是录音。只有我妈妈才可能相信这些。只有母亲才几乎会相信这些。其他成年人见到我，他们脑海中闪过的想法不是休·格兰特。他们脑海中的想法是“高个犹太人”。
Well, gosh, wouldn't they want this wonderful humanistic, intelligent reporter who looks like Hugh Grant?
天哪，难道他们不会想要这位长得像休·格兰特、既人性化又聪明的优秀记者吗？
All right. Yeah, let's move on.
好了。好的，我们继续吧。
What's the theme for this week?
这周的主题是什么？
The theme for this week is new beginnings. And we have several stories, people telling about various ways in which their life began anew at some point.
这周的主题是“新的开始”。我们有几个故事，人们讲述了他们生活中在某个节点以各种方式重新开始的故事。
That's very interesting, because I just did an interview this morning with a newspaper reporter about roman--
这很有趣，因为我今天早上刚接受了一位报纸记者的采访，关于浪漫——
I'm just going to stop the tape again. This is my whole life. I call my mom for an interview, and it's not even her first interview of the day. I was lucky to get a booking. She's a therapist, and sometimes she gets called by the papers and stuff.
我又要停掉录音了。这就是我的全部生活。我给妈妈打电话做采访，这甚至不是她今天的第一场采访。我能约到她算我运气好。她是心理治疗师，有时候报社之类的人会找她。
--mance, romantic love. And people's expectations about relationships. And one of the things I believe is that there are a lot of people who are good at beginnings, but they're not good at middles.
——浪漫的爱。以及人们对关系的期望。我相信的一点是，很多人擅长开始，但不擅长过程。
Which means what?
这意味着什么？
It means that they like the beginning, where there's all this idealization and romantic projections. And the other person can be who they think they should be, rather than who they are. And when they get to the middle phase--
这意味着他们喜欢开始阶段，那时候充满了理想化和浪漫的投射。对方可以是他们认为应该是的样子，而不是原本的样子。当他们进入中间阶段——
All right. I'm just going to stop the tape. Listen, all of you in the audience right now, let's just agree right now, it's the very beginning of our relationship. It's the very beginning of our radio relationship right now. This is our little first little radio date, and I just don't want any idealizing on either side. OK? Let's just make eye contact right now. Remember what Joe Franklin said about the eye contact. No idealizing.
好了。我又要停掉录音了。听着，现在在座的各位听众，让我们现在就达成共识，这是我们关系的起点。这是我们广播关系的起点。这是我们的第一次广播约会，我不希望任何一方有任何理想化，好吗？现在让我们进行眼神交流。记住乔·富兰克林关于眼神交流的话。不要理想化。
--where there's more of a reality-based relationship, they run away from it because it's not as exciting.
——也就是关系变得更加基于现实时，他们会逃避，因为那没那么令人兴奋。
It's interesting that you say that because, actually, as we've approached the first show, I've realized that I am much more comfortable with the notion of every day, work-a-day radio work, and being on every week, and having pieces on the air. But the notion of saying in a really big way, "OK, this is the beginning. It's the beginning, and we're going to have a big beginning, and we're going to make an epic statement," I feel very uncomfortable with.
你说得很有趣，因为事实上，随着第一期节目的临近，我意识到我更适应那种每天按部就班的广播工作，每周都上节目，有内容播出。但如果要以一种非常宏大的方式说：“好了，这就是开始。这是一个开始，我们将要有一个宏大的开端，我们要发表一番史诗般的宣言，”对此我感到非常不舒服。
So you are good at middles.
所以你擅长过程。
I'm better, I think, at middles than at beginnings.
我想我比起开始，更擅长处理过程。
That's good. That's good because practically all of life is the middle.
那很好。那很好，因为实际上生活的全部就是过程。
We have gotten so deep here. I never expected that it was going to get so deep. I'm just very pleased at how deep this has gotten. Now you're sitting there, you're thinking, "Is he making fun of me? What's happening now? Where are you?" No, I'm not. I'm not, actually. I'm not. I'm not. I'm not. You have nothing to worry about.
我们谈得太深了。我从没想过会谈得这么深。我很高兴能谈得这么深入。现在你坐在那里，你心想：“他在取笑我吗？现在发生了什么？你在哪里？”不，我没有。我真的没有。我没有。你没什么可担心的。
Are we going to get a tape of this since we're outside the Chicago listening area?
既然我们在芝加哥收听区域之外，我们能拿到这份录音吗？
Depending on how you sound, yeah.
取决于你表现得如何，可以。
OK.
好的。
Well, that's my mom, Shirley Glass, speaking to us from Baltimore. I don't think she's going to get a tape. I do not think she's going to get a tape.
好的，那就是我妈妈，雪莉·格拉斯，在巴尔的摩和我们通话。我觉得她拿不到录音。我觉得她拿不到录音。
Well, next on our little playhouse stage, we have Mr. Lawrence Steger. Now those of you who have been listening carefully to our program and taking notes, and I know there are many of you out there, you know what I'm supposed to do at this point. You know because you were listening carefully to Joe Franklin at the very beginning of our program.
好了，接下来在我们的剧场舞台上，有劳伦斯·斯泰格先生。那些一直在仔细收听我们节目并做笔记的人——我知道你们中间有很多这样的人——你们知道我现在该做什么。你们知道，因为你们在节目开始时一直在仔细听乔·富兰克林的话。
Above all, get the plug fast.
最重要的是，赶紧打广告。
That's right. Well, thank you, Joe Franklin. Lawrence Steger is a filmmaker and a performance artist, just back from performing in Glasgow, Scotland. He's going back there in January to collaborate with the performance artist, Ron Athey, who lives here in Chicago. And basically, we contacted Lawrence, and we told him the story that you heard over the course of the last half-hour, Kevin Kelly's story, this guy who believes he only has six months to live, goes on this cross-country road trip.
没错。好吧，谢谢你，乔·富兰克林。劳伦斯·斯泰格是一位电影制作人和表演艺术家，刚从苏格兰格拉斯哥演出回来。一月份他将回去与居住在芝加哥的表演艺术家罗恩·阿西合作。基本上，我们联系了劳伦斯，告诉了他你们在过去半小时里听到的故事，凯文·凯利的故事，那个认为自己只剩六个月生命的人，开始了一场横跨全国的公路旅行。
And as it turned out, when Lawrence Steger found out, the day that he found out that he was HIV positive, this was five years ago, on that day, it was the exact day that he and a friend left on a cross-country car trip. So we commissioned him to do a little piece about his experience. And here it is.
结果证明，劳伦斯·斯泰格查出自己呈艾滋病毒阳性的那天，正好是他和朋友出发去进行横跨全国公路旅行的日子，那是五年前。所以我们委托他创作了一段关于他经历的短片。就在这里。
Title. Road. Treatment. It's shot entirely on video, mostly handheld. Shaky, out of focus, bad color. Overblown color actually. Sort of the way colors are separated on an old television console, yet still has all the outlines of the images repeated. The outlines of the images, the silhouettes, repeated over and over, ad nauseam, and fading into each other.
标题：《道路》、《治疗》。全程用视频拍摄，大多是手持。摇晃，失焦，颜色糟糕。其实是颜色过饱和。就像旧电视机上颜色分离的方式，但仍然有所有图像的轮廓重复着。图像的轮廓，剪影，一遍又一遍地重复，令人作呕，并相互融合。
Can I get this microphone adjusted a little, so I don't have to lean over so much?
能把这个麦克风调一下吗，这样我就不用弯腰那么多了？
Yeah, sure. Just pull that.
好的，没问题。拉一下那个。
Check one, two, three. Sound better? Yeah. Sorry. Thanks.
测试一、二、三。声音好点了吗？好的。抱歉。谢谢。
Synopsis. The story concerns Luke, gay, white, Midwestern, late twenties. Follows Luke on the day that he is informed of his HIV positive status. Luke cops a stance of cold, brittle, not unlike the Harrison Ford narration on Blade Runner, but there's a hint of vulnerability to Luke.
概要。故事关于卢克，男同性恋，白人，中西部人，二十多岁。讲述了卢克得知自己艾滋病毒呈阳性那一天的经历。卢克摆出一种冷漠、生硬的姿态，有点像《银翼杀手》里哈里森·福特的旁白，但卢克身上有一丝脆弱感。
Have we got the Harrison Ford or the Rutger Hauer voice?
我们用的是哈里森·福特还是鲁特格尔·哈尔的声音？
Yeah.
是的。
Great. Roll it.
太棒了。开始放。
Enhance 5719. Track 45 left.
增强5719。追踪45号左侧。
Great. Take it under me. That's great. Story follows Luke. He's accompanied by his college buddy, Bill, and both are packed for a road trip across the country to San Francisco.
太棒了。把它压在我声音下面。太好了。故事跟随卢克。他由大学好友比尔陪同，两人都收拾好了行李，准备横跨全国去旧金山。
This isn't the right section of Blade Runner. Can you just kill the Blade Runner?
这不是《银翼杀手》对的部分。你能把《银翼杀手》的配乐关了吗？
Locations. Car interior. Gas station exterior. HIV clinic parking lot. HIV clinic interior. Highway. Music. Strauss's four last songs, particularly "Ruhe, meine Seele!" sung by Dame Janet Baker.
地点。汽车内部。加油站外部。艾滋病诊所停车场。艾滋病诊所内部。高速公路。音乐：施特劳斯的《最后四首歌》，特别是珍妮特·贝克夫人演唱的《入睡吧，我的灵魂！》。
Can you take it under me? Hold.
你能把它压在我声音下面吗？停。
Follows Luke and his friend Bill to the gas station and to the clinic, the last stop before getting on the highway.
跟随卢克和他的朋友比尔去加油站，然后去诊所，那是上高速公路前的最后一站。
OK. Take it out. Take out the Janet Baker.
好的。关掉它。关掉珍妮特·贝克的音乐。
Bill loads one hits of pot while driving on the way to the gas station and to the clinic.
比尔在去加油站和诊所的路上，一边开车一边抽大麻。
Can we nix that Strauss music? It's too mournful. There's really no music on the soundtrack. It's stark, crisp. Maybe some songs coming from the radio at the clinic's desk?
我们能去掉那首施特劳斯的音乐吗？太忧伤了。配乐里其实不该有音乐。应该是冷峻、干脆的。也许诊所前台的收音机里传出几首歌？
[RADIO STATIC]
[收音机静电声]
Great. And definitely from the car radio mixed with surfing on an AM radio. No music.
太棒了。绝对要从车载收音机里传出来，混合着AM电台搜台的声音。不要音乐。
The drama is constantly being undermined through the cool, collective quality of Luke's demeanor. He seems detached, quote, "I am not sure how I feel. I feel a little sad, sort of mad. I guess blank. But I'm OK. I'm sure I'll get a handle on it," end quote. Luke thinks he's sounding like a short story assignment in a creative writing class or, worse, trapped inside an artsy novel.
戏剧性一直在被卢克冷淡、集体的态度所削弱。他显得疏离，引用：“我不确定我的感受。我感到有点难过，有点生气。我想是一片空白。但我还好。我相信我会处理好的，”引用结束。卢克觉得自己听起来像创意写作课上的短篇小说作业，或者更糟，被困在了一部矫揉造作的小说里。
Luke imagines himself in a television dramatization of himself. Camera pulls back from behind Luke's head, sort of on a mini-crane. Camera floats, hovers over the back of Luke's head. "The ceiling of the car must be incredibly high," he thinks to himself.
卢克想象自己身处一部关于自己的电视剧情中。摄像机从卢克脑后拉开，就像在一个小型摇臂上。摄像机漂浮着，悬停在卢克脑后。他心想：“车顶一定高得离谱。”
Bill pulls into the closest parking spot in the clinic, blows out the last of the one-hit, and, as he's knocking the brass pipe into the ashtray, turns to Luke with that slightly watery look in his eyes from too much intake. Luke takes it as one of those Care Bear looks that he's experienced before from Bill. A little clumsy since Bill has to force his face into a sympathetic posture. Quick close-up on the corner of Bill's mouth.
比尔把车停进诊所最近的停车位，吐出最后一口烟，当他把铜烟斗磕在烟灰缸里时，转头看向卢克，眼睛里带着那种因为吸入过量而产生的微湿神情。卢克把它当成了一种他以前从比尔那里体会过的“爱心熊”式的眼神。由于比尔不得不强迫自己的脸做出同情的姿态，显得有点笨拙。快速特写比尔嘴角的瞬间。
There's a moment of anger flashing in Luke when he registers Bill's look. When Bill asks him, "What are you thinking about?" Luke responds, "Who's thinking? Nothing." "I hate thinking I'm in a novel," he thinks to himself. Cut to interior of the clinic, the reception area.
当卢克意识到比尔的眼神时，内心闪过一丝愤怒。当比尔问他：“你在想什么？”卢克回答：“谁在想？什么也没想。”他对自己想：“我讨厌觉得自己活在小说里。”切换到诊所内部，接待区。
Can we change this sound bed here?
我们可以换掉这段背景音吗？
[ROMANTIC MUSIC PLAYING]
[浪漫音乐播放]
Great. Take it down just a-- Great.
太棒了。声音调小一点——太好了。
In the scene that we talked about on the phone, the clinic waiting room scene, that scene flips back and forth between various security black-and-white cameras mounted at the ceilings. The nurse assigned to Luke's anonymous number is a black drag queen named Stephanie, who wears a full nurse's outfit complete with a little paper hat that sits atop of her freshly coiffed hairdo. She's the only one in the clinic who wears a real uniform. Stephanie has the longest fingernails that Luke has ever seen on anyone. Luke thinks briefly about how the fingernails keep on growing even after a person dies, but he pushes that thought away with this fingers to his forehead, wonders why he is thinking about that. It's that novel thing again.
在我们电话里谈到的场景，即诊所候诊室场景中，那个场景在安装在天花板上的各种安保黑白摄像头之间来回切换。分配给卢克匿名编号的护士是一位名叫斯蒂芬妮的黑人变装皇后，她穿着全套护士装，头上戴着一顶纸质小帽子，罩在她精心打理的发型上。她是诊所里唯一穿真正制服的人。斯蒂芬妮有着卢克见过的最长的指甲。卢克短暂地想到指甲在人死后还会继续生长，但他用手指按住前额把这个想法推开，奇怪自己为什么会想到这个。又是那种小说情节。
Stephanie, the drag queen nurse, walks Luke back to the small cubicles that the tests are administered in and then used to relay the results. Luke's narrator imagines how many people have been in these cubicles and what they would look like if they were all piled on top of one another. Piles of tested bodies. Cut to Stephanie closing the hollow core door, makes that hollow core door sound.
变装皇后护士斯蒂芬妮领着卢克回到进行检测的小隔间，那里也被用来传达结果。卢克的旁白想象着有多少人进过这些小隔间，如果他们都堆在一起会是什么样子。一堆被检测过的尸体。切换到斯蒂芬妮关上空心门，发出那种空心门特有的声音。
Do we have that on cart?
我们有那个推车吗？
[SOUND OF HOLLOW DOOR CLOSING]
[空心门关闭的声音]
Perfect. Maybe a shot from a security camera that shows all of the cubicles in the clinic. Luke imagines himself in a George Tooker painting that was reproduced in his sixth grade reader. He wonders what his sixth grade teacher would think of Stephanie. He wonders if his sixth grade teacher was ever tested. He imagines her body in the pileup of bodies who have come to the clinic.
完美。也许可以从一个能看到诊所所有隔间的监控摄像头拍一个镜头。卢克想象自己置身于一幅乔治·塔克（George Tooker）的画中，那幅画曾印在他六年级的读本里。他想知道他六年级的老师会怎么看斯蒂芬妮。他想知道他六年级的老师是否接受过测试。他想象着她的身体混在那群来到诊所的人体堆中。
Stephanie has been saying something, and Luke has to blink his eyes again to refocus. He explains to Stephanie that he has been expecting this result, that he's experienced a large share of AIDS, cared for, and, likewise, buried lots of his friends. But it doesn't seem to come as a surprise. Stephanie says, "You can cry or hold my hand. I just want you to sit for a moment and let it sink in." Luke thinks, "Whatever."
斯蒂芬妮一直在说些什么，卢克不得不再次眨眼以重新集中注意力。他向斯蒂芬妮解释说，他一直预料到这个结果，他经历过很多艾滋病病例，照顾过，也同样埋葬过许多朋友。但这似乎并不令人惊讶。斯蒂芬妮说：“你可以哭，也可以握住我的手。我只是想让你坐一会儿，让这一切沉淀下来。”卢克心想：“随便吧。”
Cut to Bill in waiting room, flipping through People 's The Year in Pictures. Cut back to close-up of Luke, forehead wrinkled. He thinks his narrator wants him to get out of the cubicle. He waits for Stephanie to finish her spiel, thanks her, and shakes her hand, getting a slight scrape from one of the fingernails. Close-up on Luke's hand, no scratch. The walls seem to pulsate as Luke walks down the hallway to the reception area. He tries to be as blank as possible to Bill.
切到在候诊室里的比尔，正翻看着《人物》杂志的《年度图片》。切回卢克的特写镜头，他眉头紧锁。他觉得他的叙述者想让他离开隔间。他等斯蒂芬妮说完那些话，向她道谢并与她握手，指甲不小心在他手上划了一道浅痕。卢克手部的特写，没有伤痕。当卢克穿过走廊走向接待区时，墙壁似乎在搏动。他尽量对比尔表现得面无表情。
I'm not sure about this final section. I know that we talked about it ending on the highway with the car being surrounded by bikers on their way to the Sturgis bikers' rally. But now I like the idea of it ending on the highway entrance ramp.
我不确定最后这一部分。我知道我们讨论过把它定在高速公路上，车被一群去参加斯特吉斯摩托车集会的骑手包围。但现在我喜欢让它结束在高速公路入口坡道上的想法。
Cut to interior of car pulling out of parking lot. Luke keeps looking straight ahead, as he murmurs, "I'm positive." Long, slow pan from the back of Luke's head to the back of Bill's. There's no reaction in either of their faces or, better, the profiles of their faces. This is the longest shot. They don't look at each other.
切到从停车场驶出的车内。卢克一直直视前方，喃喃自语：“我是阳性。”从卢克的后脑勺慢慢横移到比尔的后脑勺。他们两人的脸上都没有表情，或者更好的是，两人的侧脸都没有反应。这是最长的镜头。他们没有看对方。
Perhaps this scene would be shot in blue screen with the camera in the backseat and the sky surrounding the two heads of Bill and Luke having that old, scratchy, 16 millimeter time lapse exposure, so the clouds seem to be moving at a rapid pace. Flickers, flips back and forth between real sky and blue screen backdrop. Voice comes up on a car radio. "Trying not to think of the future. Just live in the present moment." Something like that. You got that? It comes onto the radio.
也许这个场景可以用蓝屏拍摄，摄像机放在后座，比尔和卢克的两个头周围的天空用那种老式、带划痕的16毫米延时曝光拍摄，让云彩看起来移动得很快。在真实天空和蓝屏背景之间闪烁、翻转。车载收音机里传出声音。“试着不去想未来。就活在当下。”之类的。你明白吗？它在收音机里响起。
I also decided that it was an entirely unnatural and inhumane way to live, and that having a future is part of what being human is about, and that when you take away the future for humans, you take away a lot of the humanness, and that it's not actually a very good thing to live entirely in the present, that one needs to have a past.
我还认为那是一种完全不自然、不人道的生活方式，拥有未来是身为人类的一部分，当你剥夺了人类的未来，你就剥夺了很大一部分人性，实际上，完全活在当下并不是一件好事，人需要拥有过去。
Luke comments to Bill, "Live entirely in the present, huh?" Bill drives and looks out the corner of his right eye to see what position Luke is holding his head in. Luke looks outside passenger window and, every once in a while, turns to glance at Bill. Long pause. There's dead air. Cut to Luke's point of view. Car is pulling onto entrance ramp of highway. Luke sees hitchhiker with a sign that he stands for any remote meaning to the narrative. Luke sees himself outside of his own story. He can't read the hitchhiker's sign. He knows that he's on a long silent journey. He leans over to turn off the radio. Cut to black.
卢克对比尔说：“完全活在当下，是吗？”比尔开着车，用右眼的余光看着卢克头部的姿势。卢克看着车窗外，偶尔转头瞥一眼比尔。长久的沉默。一片死寂。切到卢克的视角。车子正驶入高速公路入口坡道。卢克看到一个搭便车的路人举着一个牌子，他代表了叙事中任何遥远的意义。卢克看到了故事之外的自己。他读不懂搭车人的牌子。他知道自己正在进行一段漫长而无声的旅程。他俯身关掉收音机。切成黑色。
[MUSIC - "(UH-OH) GET OUT OF THE CAR" BY THE TRENIERS]
[音乐 - The Treniers 演唱的 “(Uh-Oh) Get Out of the Car”]
Well, Lawrence Steger is a Chicago performance artist and filmmaker.
嗯，劳伦斯·斯蒂格（Lawrence Steger）是一位芝加哥行为艺术家和电影制作人。
This is Your Radio Playhouse. I'm Ira Glass. OK, what am I doing right now? What am I doing right now? That's right. That's right. Eye contact.
这里是《广播剧场》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。好的，我现在在做什么？我现在在做什么？对了。对了。眼神交流。
Look right in the eye. Eye contact is everything.
看着眼睛。眼神交流就是一切。
That's right. Advice from the master. OK. Let's review our program so far. Let's just review. Let's just get things straight right now. Our stories so far have been about people whose futures were taken from them and were thrown into the present in one way or another.
没错。来自大师的建议。好的。让我们回顾一下目前的节目。让我们回顾一下。让我们现在把事情理清楚。到目前为止，我们的故事讲述的是那些未来被夺走，以某种方式被迫活在当下的人们。
I guess when any big emotional moment happens, you are thrown in the present in a really aggressive, aggressive way, whether you choose to or not. You have this hyper sense of reality. Well, the next story is about someone whose future was taken from him when he was wrongly imprisoned for 20 years. And his sentence was commuted two years ago. And he found himself reborn into everyday life.
我想当任何重大的情感时刻发生时，无论你是否选择，你都会以一种非常剧烈、非常强硬的方式被抛入当下。你会有一种超现实的感觉。嗯，下一个故事是关于一个未来被夺走的人，他被错误监禁了20年。两年前他的刑期被减免了。他发现自己重生到了日常生活中。
It was like I just-- I don't know. It seemed like the oxygen was even different. You know what I mean? The air seemed to be thinner.
就像我只是——我不知道。似乎氧气都不一样了。你明白我的意思吗？空气似乎变稀薄了。
I'll tell you what's been a real kick for me, getting up, cooking breakfast. Making pancakes, and eggs, and bacon, and stuff like that. It sounds drab maybe to the common-- everybody would think of that as, "That's really drab." But for me, that's really exciting. And that's one of the things I always dreamed of doing. I also dreamt of finding a very lovely lady, and I have. Inside, I'm happy. Inside.
我告诉你什么让我真正感到兴奋，起床，做早餐。做薄煎饼、鸡蛋、培根之类的东西。对于普通人来说这可能听起来很枯燥——每个人都会觉得，“那真是太枯燥了。”但对我来说，这真的很令人兴奋。这是我一直梦想做的事情之一。我还梦想找到一位可爱的女士，我也找到了。内心深处，我很快乐。在内心深处。
This is Ed Ryder. He was in prison for murder and was doing time in Graterford Prison in Pennsylvania. And a few years ago, a key witness who had testified against him admitted to lying while under oath, and other evidence came forward. He was made a free man. Back when he was in Graterford Prison, he played trumpet, and he sang with a jazz band. And that whole time, he dreamed of this new life, a new life that he would have outside as a professional musician. And that's what he's working on. That's what he's working on right now. And he's playing. He doesn't have a CD yet, but he's playing gigs in the real world.
这是埃德·莱德（Ed Ryder）。他因谋杀罪入狱，在宾夕法尼亚州的格雷特福德监狱服刑。几年前，一名曾指控他的关键证人承认在宣誓下撒谎，随后出现了其他证据。他被释放了。当他在格雷特福德监狱时，他吹小号，并在一个爵士乐队唱歌。在那段时间里，他一直梦想着这种新生活，一种他出狱后作为职业音乐家可以拥有的新生活。这就是他正在努力的目标。这就是他现在正在努力的方向。他在演奏。他还没有CD，但他在现实世界中参加演出。
The first time I played, when I got out of prison, I didn't feel compelled to be so exact like I did when I was at Graterford. Inmates are the worst, critical people in the world. They criticize anything you do. In prison, you have a lot of musicians. After all, musicians, they don't make no money, so I guess the first place you find them at is in prison. But you have a lot of guys who are musicians.
当我出狱后第一次演奏时，我并不觉得有必要像在格雷特福德时那样精准。囚犯是世界上最刻薄的评论家。他们会批评你做的任何事。在监狱里，有很多音乐家。毕竟，音乐家赚不到钱，所以我想你能找到他们的第一个地方就是监狱。但你有很多家伙是音乐家。
And even though they might not be actively playing anymore, they'll be quick to criticize you, whether the chord is not right, or whether you didn't flatten the ninth, whether you didn't raise this fifth, or you guys didn't play the changes right. Although it might not have took away from the structure of the music, it's just that, I guess you can say that prisoners have a tendency to think like classical musicians would. Everything has to be perfect and exact the way it's heard. And everything has to be like that. There's no going against the grain.
即使他们可能不再活跃演奏了，他们也会很快批评你，无论和弦不对，还是你没有降九音，或者你没有升五音，或者你们改动得不对。虽然这可能并没有削弱音乐的结构，但你只能说，囚犯往往会像古典音乐家那样思考。一切都必须完美且完全按照听到的那样。一切都必须那样。没有违背常规的余地。
And here, in the world, people are a little different. They don't concern themselves so much with that, as much as how are you entertaining us? How are you helping us to feel better about ourselves? How are you making us feel better? At Graterford, there is nothing you can do to make them feel better, except to release them.
而在现实世界里，人们有点不同。他们并不太关心这些，更关心的是你如何娱乐我们？你如何帮助我们自我感觉更好？你如何让我们感觉更好？在格雷特福德，你除了释放他们，什么也做不了让他们感觉更好。
So if you can play for a Graterford audience, you don't even look for an applause. Just as long as they don't boo you, you're all right. If they can't find nothing wrong with the music, they'll tell you, "You just didn't turn right. When you had the horn up, you didn't hold it on a 45 degree angle. It didn't look right." So they'll find something.
所以，如果你能在格雷特福德的观众面前演奏，你甚至不需要掌声。只要他们不嘘你，你就还好。如果他们找不到音乐有什么毛病，他们会告诉你：“你刚才转得不对。当你举起号角时，你没有把它保持在45度角。看起来不对。”所以他们会挑出点毛病。
Now you know how we heard people earlier in the program talk about the importance of living in the present. But when we interviewed Ed Ryder, he pointed out that, in prison, the most important thing is to keep your eye on the future, on the day that you're going to get out. And that the guys who just live in the present do really badly, because, of course, the present is so terrible.
现在你知道我们之前在节目中听到人们谈论活在当下的重要性了。但当我们采访埃德·莱德时，他指出，在监狱里，最重要的是时刻关注未来，关注你获释的那一天。那些只活在当下的人过得非常糟糕，因为当然，现在的生活太糟糕了。
I think when I was in prison, I dreamed more about the future in my head. I just had a lot of plans, a lot of things that I just dreamed about, I just dreamed of doing and dreamed of accomplishing. You're forced almost to. You know what I mean? You have nothing else to look forward to but tomorrow. You're constantly hoping and hoping. You're trying to plan something for the future.
我想当我在监狱里时，我在脑海中更多地梦想未来。我只是有很多计划，很多我梦想着做和梦想着完成的事情。你几乎是被迫的。你明白我的意思吗？除了明天，你没有什么可期待的。你不断地希望和祈祷。你试图为未来规划点什么。
We asked him if he is still playing the same music now that his future is here and he's out. And we thought that maybe the songs that he used to play would just bring back these hard memories of prison that he'd rather just as soon avoid. But he said, no, he plays the same numbers now that he used to, though sometimes they mean something different to him today.
我们问他，既然他的未来已经到来，他也出来了，他是否还在演奏同样的音乐。我们以为他以前弹的歌可能会勾起他宁愿避开的关于监狱的痛苦回忆。但他说是的，他现在演奏的曲目和他以前演奏的一样，尽管有时它们今天对他来说有不同的含义。
When I was in Graterford, I always listened to it. I had a tape of "God Bless the Child That's Got His Own" by Billie Holiday. And what it meant to me when I was at Graterford-- and it has the same meaning now, but it's different. In the sense that, when I was at Graterford, when she said, "Them that's got shall get, Them that's not shall lose. So the Bible says, and it still is news. Mama may have, Papa may have, But God bless the child that has his own."
当我在格雷特福德时，我总是听它。我有一盘比莉·霍利戴（Billie Holiday）唱的《God Bless the Child That's Got His Own》的磁带。当我在格雷特福德时，它的含义对我来说是——现在也是同样的含义，但不同了。意思是，当她在格雷特福德时，她说：“有的人会得到，没有的人会失去。圣经是这么说的，而且现在仍然是新闻。妈妈可能有，爸爸可能有，但上帝保佑拥有自己东西的孩子。”
Well, in my mind, at Graterford, I thought that, yes, I was the child that had his own, because I was out here on my own. I had no help at the time. There was no hope. I seen no way. I was like a child. I was like a child because I had no one I can turn to. My parents had passed. I had no one I could turn to.
嗯，在我心里，在格雷特福德，我想，是的，我是那个拥有自己东西的孩子，因为我在外面靠自己。那时我没有帮助。没有希望。我看不出出路。我像个孩子。我像个孩子，因为我没有人可以求助。我的父母已经去世了。我没有人可以求助。
And I felt like every time I would listen to that, I felt as though she was talking directly to me. And for me, that meant that I was on my own in this prison situation. And I was going to have to make it the best way that I could. And I was going to have to muster all the energy that I could possibly muster. Now when I was released and I heard the same song again, it still had that meaning, but now it's a different-- I'm on my own differently because I'm not in prison anymore.
我觉得每次我听那首歌时，我都觉得她是在直接对我说话。对我来说，这意味着在这种监狱的情况下我必须靠自己。我必须以我能做到的最好方式去完成它。我必须鼓起我所能鼓起的所有力量。现在当我获释并再次听到同一首歌时，它仍然有那种含义，但现在它不同了——我以不同的方式依靠自己，因为我不在监狱里了。
That's not the struggle no more. It's me. But I'm on my own now because I've got things that I have to do. I have responsibilities now that I have to take care of. I have bills that I have to pay. I have job responsibility.
那不再是挣扎了。是我自己。但我现在靠自己，因为我有必须要做的事情。我现在有必须承担的责任。我有必须支付的账单。我有工作责任。
I have a lot of other things that I have to do, and I have to do these things on my own now. I don't have no prison guards waking me up in the morning, telling me, "Hey, it's time to get up," or "It's time to go eat, " or "It's time where you guys can go to a shower." I don't have that anymore. I'm on my own. So all this now is dependent upon me and my own initiative.
我还有很多其他必须做的事情，我必须现在靠自己完成这些事情。我没有监狱看守早上叫醒我，告诉我，“嘿，该起床了，”或者“该去吃饭了，”或者“该去淋浴了。”我不再有那些了。我靠自己。所以现在这一切都取决于我和我自己的主动性。
[SINGING] Them that's got shall get, them that's not will lose. So the Bible said, and it still is news. Mama may have, Papa may have, but God bless the child that's got his own, that's got his own. You know the strong get more, while the weak ones fade. Empty pockets don't, they don't make the grade. Mama may have, Papa may have, but God bless the child that's got his own, that's got his own. Money, you've got lots of friends. They all keep hanging around your door. But when money's gone and all of the spendings end, they don't come around, they won't come around no more. Rich relations give a crust of bread and such. Go on and help yourself, but you better not take too much. Mama may have, Papa may have, but God bless the child that's got his own. God bless the child that's got his own.
[歌唱] 有的人会得到，没有的人会失去。圣经是这么说的，而且现在仍然是新闻。妈妈可能有，爸爸可能有，但上帝保佑拥有自己东西的孩子，拥有自己东西的孩子。你知道强者得到更多，而弱者却在凋零。空口袋不能，他们不能成功。妈妈可能有，爸爸可能有，但上帝保佑拥有自己东西的孩子，拥有自己东西的孩子。钱啊，你有很多朋友。他们都挂在你家门口。但当钱花光了，花费结束了，他们就不会再来了，他们再也不会来了。富有的亲戚会给一点面包之类的东西。去拿吧，帮助自己，但你最好别拿太多。妈妈可能有，爸爸可能有，但上帝保佑拥有自己东西的孩子。上帝保佑拥有自己东西的孩子。
That's basically some of it.
基本上就是这些。
Ed Ryder joining us in the playhouse from the studios of WHYY in Philadelphia, speaking with me and associate producer Nancy Updike. Ed Ryder's a big Billie Holiday fanatic. That was the word he used, "fanatic," when we asked him about it. So when we asked him to play a number with his horn, with his trumpet, he played "Lover Man."
埃德·莱德在费城WHYY工作室加入了我们的剧场，与我和助理制作人南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）交谈。埃德·莱德是比莉·霍利戴的超级粉丝。这是他自己用的词，“粉丝”，当我们问他这件事时。所以当我们让他用他的号角，用他的小号吹一首歌时，他演奏了《Lover Man》。
[MUSIC - "LOVER MAN" BY BILLIE HOLIDAY]
[音乐 - 比莉·霍利戴的《Lover Man》]
That's pretty much all the time we have for this evening.
我们今晚的时间差不多了。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助鸣谢]
This show was produced by Dolores Wilber, Peter Clowney, Nancy Updike, Alix Spiegel, and myself. Contributing editors Paul Tough and Jack Hitt on the west coast, Margy Rochlin on the east coast. I've got that backwards. Paul Tough and Jack Hitt on the east coast. Margy Rochlin on the west. You see, you get so confused when you have two pieces of music running at the same time.
本节目由多洛雷斯·威尔伯（Dolores Wilber）、彼得·克劳尼（Peter Clowney）、南希·厄普代克、亚历克斯·斯皮格尔（Alix Spiegel）和我本人制作。贡献编辑保罗·塔夫（Paul Tough）和杰克·希特（Jack Hitt）在西海岸，玛吉·罗克林（Margy Rochlin）在东海岸。我搞反了。保罗·塔夫和杰克·希特在东海岸。玛吉·罗克林在西海岸。你看，当你同时播放两段音乐时，你会变得非常困惑。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Torey Malatia has supported this show from the start. We'll be back next week, same time, we hope. From WBEZ Chicago, I'm Ira Glass.
托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）从一开始就支持这个节目。我们希望下周同一时间回来。来自芝加哥WBEZ，我是艾拉·格拉斯。